le v vous et partez ça devient trop
dangereux de rester ici
partez avec juste ce que vous avez sur
vous abandonner tout fuyez voilà en deux
minutes vous êtes devenus réfugiés
on ne naît pas un réfugié
on le devient et devenir réfugiés ça
n'arrive pas qu'aux autres
en algérie il ya 20 ans le pays était en
paix la population étaient vivantes les
cinémas les théâtres été très envie et
très rapidement tout s'est dégradé
on a commencé par tuer des journalistes
puis des artistes des enseignants puis
des gens dans la rue puis c'est devenu
trop dangereux
je me souviens de ce jour où nous étions
en classe et soudainement nous avons
entendu les coups de feu tout près de la
classe et il ne sais c'est pas la
maîtresse a eu peur et s'est mise à
hurler comme une hystérique et nous a
demandé de fuir alors on est sorti dans
la panique sous les coups de feu on
voyait des morts du sang partout et un
homme m'a attrapé il a couru avec moi
dès qu'il a vu un immeuble il est entré
dans l'immeuble
il a attendu que les coups de feu c'est
ce et lorsqu'ils ont cessé il m'a
demandé de fuir et de retrouver ma
famille je me souviens que ce jour j'ai
vraiment eu très peur mais mes parents
n'ont jamais parlé de départ mais quand
les deux frères de mon père ont été
assassinés chez nous le seul jour où ils
étaient les seuls présents dans notre
maison
il a fallu partir et il a fallu tout
pitt et moi j'étais une petite
algérienne j'avais 8 ans je ne parlaient
qu'arabe j'avais eu mon école
ma famille mes amis je comprenais pas ce
qui se passait je me souviens de notre
départ
je me souviens de la peur et du chagrin
de mes parents et je me souviens de moi
qui demande mais quand est-ce qu'on
revient quand est-ce que je vais pouvoir
retrouver ma chambre et mes parents qui
me répondent qu'on revient le plus vite
possible
oui parce que c'est ça à l'exil c'est
partir c'est abandonner tout sans savoir
quand est ce qu'on va pouvoir revenir
sans savoir quand est ce qu'on va
pouvoir retrouver sa vie on est arrivé
en france en 1996 je saurais même pas
vous dire à quelle période de l'année
ses souvenirs sont encore tellement
floue pour moi savent et l'exil vue d'un
mètre vingt c'est compliqué c'est
difficile pour un enfant de comprendre
ce qui se passe est paradoxalement un
autre arrive et ce n'est pas tellement
les difficultés matérielles qui m'ont
marqué bien que bien sûr elle existe et
vivait dans un foyer
on allait au restaurant du coeur mais
justement on a bénéficié de structures
généreuse qui nous ont aidés moi ce qui
m'a marqué c'est que j'avais pas le
droit d'aller à l'école et ça pour un
enfant c'est terrible quand je veux dire
l'enfant il a que ça pour se faire des
amis apprendre la langue et ça a duré
longtemps ce temps que je n'avais pas le
droit d'aller à l'école et c'est quand
mes parents ont eu le droit de me
scolarisés que ma vie a changé
ou plutôt que ma nouvelle vie a commencé
alors comme je ne parlait pas le
français
les maîtres d'école ne savais pas quoi
faire de moi mais ils m'ont quand même
mis en cm1 la classe qui correspondait à
mon âge mais comme je comprenais rien au
bout d'une semaine ils m'ont dit que
j'allais changer de classe et que
j'allais aller en ce dieu dont ils sont
gentils ils auraient pu le mettre en cp
et en ce2 les premières semaines ont été
difficiles mais la maîtresse ne menotté
pas elle me laissait juste me raccrocher
et j'ai réussi j'ai réussi parce que
j'ai eu l'aide d'une femme
une bénévole une mamie retraités
qui venait deux fois par semaine dans
mon école pour m'apprendre le français
et j'ai appris le français très vite en
quelques mois c'est très facile pour les
enfants et j'ai adoré cette langue et
comme on vivait dans un foyer on
m'encourageait à rester le plus
longtemps possible au centre de loisirs
à l'étude et au centre de loisirs
un animateur m'a fait faire du théâtre
et le théâtre en français j'ai adoré
j'ai tellement aimé que j'en ai fait de
plus en plus dès que j'en avais la
possibilité
et je me suis retrouvé - réfugiés
arrivés en france à 8 ans à jouer à
l'âge de 13 ans sur la scène de la
comédie française
j'ai joué sur cette scène deux à trois
fois par semaine pendant trois ans mon
amour pour cette langue m'a amené à
faire des lectures
alors j'ai lu des textes et j'ai lu à
l'assemblée nationale à paris la
convention de genève
ce texte qui crée qui définit le statut
du réfugié
c'était à l'occasion de l'appel de paris
alors j'aurais pu continuer à faire du
théâtre
neolys et il a fallu choisir et moi même
si on m'a accueilli en france
j'ai encore peur d'un nouveau départ
forcé j'ai peur d'un nouvel exil
je n'ai pas fait gaffe parce que je vis
avec cette peur que l'on doit partir de
nouveau et je n'ai pas fait théâtre
parce que mon père qui était un comédien
connu en algérie qui avait fait 15 ans
de télévision et de radio est devenu
veilleur de nuit en france
non très logiquement j'ai fait de
l'électrochimie et je suis devenu
docteur en électrochimie j'ai soutenu ma
thèse il ya quatre mois
c
ouf
[Applaudissements]
il y a vingt ans je ne parlait pas le
français il y à 20 ans j'étais zune
exilés mais aujourd'hui je suis une
française de coeur d'esprit de culture
de nationalité aussi la france c'est mon
pays mais je suis toujours une enfant de
réfugiés quand on est réfugié on n'est
pas amnésique quand on est accueillis on
le sait on en est conscients même enfant
on en a conscience et c'est sûrement la
raison pour laquelle je travaille autant
je fais ce que je peux pour rendre à ce
pays ce qu'il va donner mais mon
histoire n'est pas l'histoire d'une
intégration
d'ailleurs j'aime pas trop ce terme je
le trouve écrasant étouffant je préfère
le terme adaptation acclimatation
voilà mon histoire n'est pas l'histoire
d'une acclimatation mon histoire c'est
l'histoire d'un accueil
parce que c'est ça dont il s'agit et cet
accueil à des visages c'est cette
maîtresse cette grand-mère cet animateur
ces personnes qui m'ont permis de
m'acclimater aussi facilement et
d'apprendre la langue aussi vite je ne
suis pas née française et pourtant je le
suis devenu
ne sous-estimons pas le pouvoir
la force et la traction de la france
croire qu'on ne peut pas accueillir ces
ne pas croire en nous et c'est surtout
se priver d'une vraie richesse
comme l'a dit ban ki moon
les exemples pour diaboliser les
réfugiés ne sont pas uniquement offensif
ils sont aussi faux et moi je sais
qu'une fois acclimater les réfugiés
deviennent des forces pour le pays
d'accueil
parce que quand on a la force de tout
quitter
on a la force de tout reconstruire
merci
[Applaudissements]